- All right, welcome back.
We are here with the cast of
"Jurassic World: Dominion."
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
So the Jurassic franchise has
increased interest in science
and dinosaurs in such a massive way
that we thought we'd play
a little game to test
our childhood knowledge of dinosaurs
that I am not feeling confident about.
This is Dino-Might
♪ Dino-Might ♪
- Teams are so strong.
It's me, Bryce, and
DaWanda versus Chris, Jeff,
and Mamoudou, who cares how they do?
Let's bring, I'm already
just talking trash,
let's bring in a host who has been around
since before the dinosaurs.
Lord, are you there?
- [Morgan] I am here, Kelly.
I'm not that old, come on now, girl.
A deity never tells his age.
- [Kelly] Look at their faces.
- That's Morgan Freeman.
Morgan Freeman, Morgan Freeman.
- [Morgan] Look at Jeff, look at Jeff.
He's all confused, he's bewildered.
Let's get to this game, come on now.
Now let me tell you about
what we're gonna play today.
- Okay.
- [Morgan] I'm gonna ask a
question about Jurassic World
or dinosaurs, spoiler, I created them.
Now, if you know the answer,
you're gonna hit your button
and score for your team.
But don't answer wrong
because steals are allowed.
Now, if the men win,
they're gonna earn a spot
on the Blake Shelton Wall of Champions.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] Whatever, whatever.
- [Morgan] However,
however, if the women win,
we're gonna welcome them as
some of the first members
of Kelly's best friends forever
but only if you win club.
I just made that up right now.
- [Kelly] It's an elite club.
- [Morgan] Yes, that's right.
Okay, so here we go, y'all ready?
- That's new.
- [Morgan] Y'all ready,
let's play here we go.
Question number one, dino
lovers who study fossils
and the history of life are known as what?
(buzzer dinging)
- Sorry, a little quicker.
- Did you just say I'm
sorry, I'm a little quicker?
- Paleontologist.
(bell dinging)
- [Morgan] That is correct.
You have scored a point.
- [Chris] Do you know what we call that?
We call that Mamou-two.
- [Morgan] Come on ladies,
pull it together, ladies.
- I was really close over
there, Mamoudou, okay?
- [Morgan] Okay now, here's
your next question everybody.
Get real quiet for this one,
'cause it's very serious.
What dinosaur might be
seen flying around the sky?
(buzzer dinging)
- Pterodactyl.
- [Morgan] It is a pterodactyl.
(bell ringing)
(audience cheering)
- Okay, I was going to say
I've got it, a pteranodon.
That's good, that's great.
- [Morgan] We would have
accepted pteranodon, yes,
or ambinguera or pterasaurus or rapforing.
I didn't make any of these
names up, it was Adam,
so let's move on now.
- Great, that's so good.
- [Morgan] Those are complicated names,
I can't understand any of that (beep).
Okay, here's the next one, okay.
What animals that live today
might be the closest living.
- Birds.
- Chicken, right, birds.
- [Morgan] A chicken is a
bird, I would accept it.
(bell dinging)
Yes, it is birds.
- Yes!
(audience applauding)
How fast are you now?
- Let's not heckle,
let's not heckle, Kelly.
Stay humble.
- [Morgan] That's right,
Tweety Bird gonna eat your ass.
Okay, now here's the next question.
What dinosaur might go by t-rex for short?
(bell dinging)
- What?
- Sorry.
- [Bryce] Oh my gosh.
- Tyrannosaurus Rex.
(bell dinging)
(crowd cheering)
- [Bryce] It's okay.
- [Morgan] Can I, it is tyrannosaurs rex.
Can I hear Jeff Goldblum?
Can I hear Jeff, can you say,
just say tyrannosaurus rex.
- Tyrannosaurus rex.
- [Morgan] Oh that feels
so good, doesn't it?
- Just when he speaks,
it's a soothing voice.
- [Morgan] Okay, it's a tie now.
We've tie now we got a tie here, folks.
Here is the next question.
What dinosaur killer
struck earth and caused
the mass extinct?
- Asteroid, asteroid.
- Asteroid.
(bell dinging)
- [Morgan] It was an asteroid.
And I take full credit for
that, I take full credit.
Sometimes you gotta clean house.
The dinosaurs didn't
spark joy for me anymore.
Okay, now this is the final question.
And this is worth double the points.
- Okay, fine.
- Winner take all.
- Oh Jeff, look, he's all
excited, oh, double the points.
Oh here we go, here we go.
- [Kelly] That's crazy.
- [Bryce] We're being heckled.
- [Morgan] What dinosaur lover wrote
the best selling book "Jurassic Park"?
(buzzer dinging)
- Michael Crichton.
- [Morgan] It was Michael Crichton
and the fellas, you have won.
You've done it, congratulations.
- Show us the wall.
(upbeat tones)
- And you know what, Kelly,
you know, who's the tallest,
is Michael Crichton, he was six nine.
- [Chris] Yeah, he was six nine.
- He was so tall.
- How tall is Blake Shelton?
- You get three points
for that, extra credit.
- Oh no!
- That puts you over the top.
- Of course, here on "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
everyone is a winner.
So to celebrate the release
of "Jurassic World: Dominion,"
everyone in the audience is getting
a pair of one day general
admission tickets to experience
Jurassic World at Universal
Studios, Hollywood.
(audience applauding)
They'll come face-to-face
with the indominus rex
from Jurassic World the Ride, and meet
Jurassic World's Blue
at the Raptor Encounter.
It's gonna be awesome.
(crowd cheering)
And because the men won for
once, their photo will be
on the Blake Shelton Wall of Champions
to Beat Kelly Clarkson, and
that also might become extinct
because I hate that wall.
"Jurassic World: Dominion" is
in theaters starting tomorrow.